what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and we know that a lot of old Fox X-Men
characters characters like Toby Maguire
Spider-Man Ben Affleck's Daredevil and a
bunch of old we'll call Legacy
characters have a pretty good chance at
making an MCU debut at some point in
time during the Multiverse Saga
everything has been set up for this to
happen and things are starting to align
pretty perfectly in Multiverse of
Madness we have already seen Doctor
Strange interact with other variants
including a fox X-Men character of
course Patrick Stewart's Professor
Xavier now we thought we were going to
see a lot more really cool variants in
that movie but unfortunately we did not
they spent most of their time in only a
few different universes however
incursions are about to start happening
in fact they've already begun in the end
of Multiverse of Madness Clea shows up
in the post-credits scene stating that
doctor strange himself has caused an
incursion and now with movies like
Deadpool 3 and Avengers Secret Wars
coming up this opens it up for a lot of
old characters to return and make their
debut in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
their first time entering the MCU and it
looks like Kevin feige does indeed have
a plan and Ryan Reynolds as well and now
it's looking like included in one of
those movies is a plan to bring back
Nicholas Cage's Ghostwriter that's right
the spirit of Vengeance and Nicholas
Cage playing him the man the myth the
legend could be entering the Marvel
Cinematic Universe according to new
reports and we'll break it all down in
this video and if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest MCU
news and if you subscribe and leave a
comment you're automatically entered in
our giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items the winner gets to pick
one item and we pick a winner at the end
of each month so if you have been
keeping up to date with all the recent
news regarding the Marvel Cinematic
Universe specifically for Deadpool 3 and
Avengers Secret Wars you know that some
old characters are indeed returning the
biggest one of course that has been
publicly out there for a long time he
himself has come out and confirmed it is
Wolverine Hugh Jackman returning as
Wolverine now he wasn't the first to do
this in the MCU and he certainly will
not be the last in fact we know Deadpool
has plans to bring back some other X-Men
as well plus secret Wars is going to be
sort of a farewell to some of these old
Legacy characters and the question that
we have right now is not if this is
going to happen the question is when
which movie is it going to be Deadpool 3
is it going to be Avengers Secret Wars
or another movie that we might not know
about that involves variants we're
unsure for a few characters but it looks
like we might have an idea of when Ghost
Rider is going to be returning and again
specifically Nicholas Cage's Ghostwriter
today we have two brand new reports
coming from reliable insiders can we get
some toast and my time to shine hello a
couple of hours ago the Twitter account
CBM shots posted a gif of Ghost Writer
Nicholas cages ghost writer and Insider
my time to shine hello retweeted this
stating now that's a cool effing shot
Glide cage is coming back winky face
then not too long after that in reply to
a Marvel perfect shots GIF of Ghost
Rider Nicholas Cage's Ghostwriter can we
get some toast retweeted it stating the
spirit's Vengeance and their Hellfire
will be burning the Damned sooner than
you think and it's interesting because
can we get some toast said the spirits
of Vengeance implying more than one
especially with the GIF that they posted
as well now it very clearly seems to be
Nicholas Cage returning for some sort of
a cameo as a ghost writer in some film
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
spoilers for The Flash if you care at
all but he also did a little cameo in
the flash as well so clearly he is not
Beyond doing cameos in superhero films
especially since he did indeed play
Ghost Rider he never actually played
Superman that never came to fruition but
since can we get some toast states that
we're going to see the spirits of
Vengeance sooner than we think that
implies that he's probably coming back
in Deadpool 3 since that movie is coming
out years before Avengers Secret Wars
and this makes sense because we know
Deadpool is going to bring back a lot of
old characters as well because we
basically know that the premise for
Deadpool 3 the plot of the movie is
going to be sort of a Deadpool kills the
Marvel Universe except they're gonna
twist it up a little bit and do what
we've been talking about Deadpool kills
the fox Universe which is an incredible
idea especially since they are literally
taking Deadpool from one Universe to the
other universe and this is an extremely
clever way to do it because make no
mistake even though Deadpool might start
off in the fox Universe for the movie he
is going to end up in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and from what we've
been hearing Hugh Jackman is going to
end up there as well or at least
eventually we've heard that Hugh Jackman
is not going to be a one and done with
Deadpool 3 but that he would in fact be
returning for Avengers Secret Wars to
play Wolverine once again now will this
be the same exact Wolverine from
Deadpool 3 that we're going to see we
are unsure we sure would like it to be
we'd love to see Deadpool and Wolverine
make their way to the MCU but it also
could be a different one it could be a
variant but if we ever hear anything
about that we'll be sure to do an update
but since Deadpool is basically going to
be fighting and killing off an entire
universe we're assuming Ghost Rider is
one of those people who pops up and
hopefully we get a pretty good fight
between Deadpool and Ghost Rider played
by Nicolas Cage but let's keep in mind
that it could be spear Ritz of Vengeance
and it could be two different Ghost
Riders it was obviously very implied
that one was indeed going to be Nicholas
Cage returning taking back up the mantle
of Ghost Rider and appearing in a Marvel
film but the other could mean great news
for Agents of Shield fans because if
there's more than one then that means
there is a possibility that one of those
could be Gabriel Luna Robbie Reyes two
different versions of Ghost Rider I know
this would make a lot of Agents of
Shield fans very happy and a lot of
people really loved Gabriel Luna as
Ghost Writer we haven't really seen a
lot of crossover yet with the Agents of
Shield characters and our Marvel
Cinematic Universe right now but we have
seen other characters show up from other
shows like the Inhumans Anson Mount
returned as Black Bolt and Doctor
Strange in the Multiverse of Madness and
that he suffered an incredibly terrible
fate and I'm kind of thinking since
Deadpool is going to be rated R these
other characters that are going to go up
against Deadpool and Wolverine are going
to suffer maybe even much worse Fates
than the Illuminati did in Multiverse
Madness and they suffered some pretty
tragic Fates however that movie was
PG-13 Deadpool 3 is definitely going to
be rated R this is confirmed by
everybody now so if The Illuminati's
deaths you thought were pretty bad wait
till Deadpool 3. now of course there is
always the possibility that they could
return in Avengers Secret Wars and if
they did that this would be very
different a very different tone than if
they would return in Deadpool 3 because
again in Deadpool 3 Deadpool is probably
going to be killing off a lot of
characters and I'm sure we'll see some
deaths in Avengers Secret Wars but for
the most part the heroes should be
fighting together to defeat King and
save their Multiverse so the cameos and
Avengers Secret Wars are going to be
much more let's just say nice however
there isn't really a reason why Nicholas
Cage couldn't appear in both Deadpool 3
and Avenger Secret Wars we could have
him in Deadpool 3 and maybe he dies
maybe he doesn't maybe he's somehow on
Deadpool's good side in Deadpool 3 and
maybe he returns in secret Wars but even
if he doesn't live that is he can still
return in secret Wars as a different
variant that is what makes the MCU so
ridiculously cool right now yes there
have been a lot of complaints by some
people however anything is really
possible right now and it's about to all
get extremely cool we're about to see a
ton of old characters return and make
their MCU debuts and it's going to be
very nostalgic and hopefully very epic
and I trust Ryan Reynolds I trust he
knows what he wants to do with Deadpool
3 and if bringing all these characters
in for cameos is what he wants to do
then I think all the fans are here for
it but go ahead and let us know your
thoughts about all of this in the
comments down below are you excited for
Nick Cage to return as as a ghost writer
if that happens and how would you like
to see him return what would the story
be if you had it your way let us know
all your thoughts down below and don't
forget to like the video and don't
forget to subscribe to the channel so
you don't miss out on any of the latest
videos you can always follow us on
Instagram and Twitter as well and as
always thank you all so much for
watching wolf wolf
thank you